in india a huge second wave of covet 19
swept through the country thousands died
crematoriums to burn the dead were
overwhelmed by the numbers they held
mass cremations sometimes people had to
make do and burn their relatives bodies
where they could ceremonies were rushed
and sometimes makeshift they continued
into the night
one crematorium worker tells dw's
namisha jaiswal his story
rajesh ojala has done with his hospital
shift for the day
working in patient care is demanding
but manageable he says
it is a far cry from the 18 months he
spent working in the mortuary through
the worst of the pandemic here
ujjala has only worked two years in
healthcare
in another life he was a performance
artist
ojala says he took to the stage at the
age of 10 and loved every bit of it
as an organizer makeup artist and dancer
all of this came to a standstill when
the pandemic hit
and ojala needed work
when a friend refused to work in the
mortuary of delhi's biggest coronavirus
hospital
ujala stepped in
during the second wave
he recounts losing track of the number
of bodies coming in
piled into
ambulances ojala worked frantically to
provide dignity to the victims families
in the chaos
there was no end to his shifts
in a space for a hundred bodies there
were two or three hundred
piled one on top of the other
and my job was to sort through these
identify and mark them
that
was the worst day of my life
and then it got
worse ujjala's younger brother took ill
ojala pleaded for a bed at the
overwhelmed hospital he worked at
but it was too late
his brother fought for life for five
days
days in which ojala wasn't given the
time off to visit him
endlessly when he started working in the
crematorium
losing her youngest compounded her fears
i never imagined this would happen to me
the second coronavirus wave will haunt
me till the day i die
i'm still terrified i have only two
children left i just want them to be
safe
i just want to spend my last years with
them
experts say that the second wave however
may be a key reason why cases are
currently low in india
tests show that coronavirus antibodies
have been found in large sections of the
indian population
essentially acting like an additional
vaccine dose
this could blunt the rise in cases
expected with omicron here
hybrid immunity which essentially means
a natural infection followed by
vaccination provides as good a
protection as three shots of vaccines
and that is a reason enough to believe
that
indian population is right now protected
in the future it might require vaccine
booster ojala is already seeing omicron
cases rise in his hospital
and doesn't expect to return to the
stage anytime soon
his hopes for 2022 are far simpler
he suspects that even this though may be
too ambitious
some extraordinary images there for more
let's bring in dw correspondent namisha
jaiswal in new delhi uh namisha as we
were just reminded in your report this
was a very tough year for india and
though the silver lining may be that
there is much hybrid immunity
authorities can't ignore the that
omicron cases are on the rise
what's the government doing about this
well michael the indian government has
responded fast to when the omicron
variant was first announced very quickly
new restrictions and guidelines were
imposed on international travel
including stricter norms for both
testing and isolation now with cases
nearing 600 in omicron alone the indian
government has also announced that
different states are going to impose
night curfews depending on the case load
that they are facing themselves now some
states have also announced restrictions
on the capacities of spas malls
restaurants new year and christmas
celebrations are also likely to be
impacted especially in big cities like
delhi and mumbai
you know i'm curious how are indians
themselves currently responding to the
omicron threat especially after this
devastating covet-19 year for them
well the second wave was definitely
devastating michael but over the last
six months india has seen a lower case
load and this has eased off
inappropriate behavior and has also
allowed for people to come out more
restrictions have been almost completely
lifted before these new recent
restrictions related to omicron we saw
massive crowds at markets and
restaurants and shopping areas
during india's festive season in
november and it continued into christmas
and the new year as well people are of
course very apprehensive about new
restrictions and lockdowns especially as
it impacted business immensely but of
course even if the people are not ready
to take up over appropriate behavior yet
the government's moves will be a
different story
after having to deal with up to half a
million deaths by the coronavirus so far
what's the progress on vaccinations
india's progress on the vaccination
front has had its peaks and troughs but
overall 60 percent of the eligible
population which is all adults have been
completely vaccinated 90 people have at
least gotten one dose of the adults that
have that are eligible or in a christmas
address the prime minister also
announced that starting on the third of
january
children from the ages of 15 to 18 will
also start getting vaccinated boosters
have also been announced for health care
workers as well as for those above 60
who are vulnerable and the scope of
these will continue to be increased
however india has only got the viral
vector vaccinations and no mrna
vaccinations that are considered to be
better for a third dose more on this
from experts in the government of course
as the new year progresses
many many thanks that is uh dw
correspondent namisha jaiswell in new
delhi
you